all right let's bring you some breaking
news coming into us here at sky news the
court in australia that has been dealing
with novak djokovic says that uh the
tennis star is to be released which
means that he will actually be able to
play in the australian open starting in
about seven days time and
defend his title and go for that record
of 21 grand slams novak of course has
been in
detention in a hotel in melbourne having
arrived in the country on what he
thought was a medical exemption from
having to have had a coveted vaccination
um there was a number of days of legal
wrangling as we said he was held in
detention and has been in court today uh
debating it with a judge
about exactly what would happen next for
the world number one but in the past few
minutes it has been announced
that uh he has won his appeal and he
will be able to take part in the
australian open defending his title and
going for a 21st grand slam
more on that story of course throughout
the day
you